but what I would say where for me the
hope lies is in two things one is that I
think you know the young are very very
interested in either the kind of action
that you talked about the kind of
protest action and it happens all over
the place in many ways and also in the
NOS the non-govermental institutions
that do Now function around the world
and do far better work than I do on a
daily basis when I'm writing um the the
other area that gives me hope is that
when I talk to Young Writers um and
indeed Young Artists they will say to me
I mean I was I was in conversation with
public conversation with a a rather
wonderful writer called Zade Smith who
you know likes to Encompass various
traditions in her work and she says you
know part of her labor part of her work
part of her life is constantly to carry
on conversations with the writers of the
past with the writers of various
Traditions or for artists of various
traditions in the past and that
conversation that ongoing conversation
feeds into the work that she do does now
and I think that's true for all of us
and for all artists and I find Hope in
that we haven't had a complete rupture
despite our culture wars we talked to
much a lot of about artist but we didn't
talk much about the the the Masterpiece
itself about the painting I think it's
also very important to know I think I
believe maybe it's too iCal but uh the
Masterpiece itself has its own energy
its own life once it's created it leaves
it it it cuts its connection with the
with its
creator and uh it continue living and
changing and evolving in our world so
and uh I think that um the greatest
possibility that we have with the
masterpieces of the art of my father's
films and I'm bringing testimony of the
people I met working on
uh on the foundation meeting the people
that uh that was saying that uh the
films art my father's can change them
they Chang their
lives if art the master artwork is
capable to have an energy to change
someone's life completely I met people
who who were scientists or Engineers
they became Priests of seeing tarkovski
films
so that's something very powerful and I
think it's not only regarding the the
the that's examples I think there all
over the world and uh it could happen
with all the paintings and artworks and
musical pieces so if we have this we
still can have hope and this film is
about the Hope nonetheless the the the
the situation was so grim and my my
father in my documentar is was very very
negative about the reality of things but
he never left
an the idea that there's always
something that we have tend to until we
leave we have to evolve spiritually and
that's actually I think the dedication
he gave to all of us well film dedicated
to to to me personally but it's
dedicated to all the children that
coming
afterwards this idea that you know with
we clearly are imperfect you know and uh
but there isn't much more than we can do
to work on those imperfections work it
collectively no more understand more uh
also about what we about these
imperfections um and for me that
actually is the um the greatest source
of hope it's this fact that we can learn
as a world clearly we do that with ups
and downs um art plays a very important
role in the sense for me it's a kind of
an antenna or it's a radio screen
where you see things you know blips of a
of a very very uh distant future but I
think um what we do need is this uh
sense of I would say it's not ownership
it certainly is responsibility I mean uh
it's not that time pushes us you know
unwillingly in a certain direction we uh
we know it's all it's self-inflicted
right it's this is the world that we
create together and um
and the hope is by understanding more
about it I think about ourselves about
how we interact how this all came to
being that uh and I think you know act
in the end you know very very very basic
human skills of uh patience uh trust
dialogue uh things that are you know as
important now as they were in in distant
past and distant Futures I think that's
actually the way that we uh can carry
that
responsibility frud was um practically
people of nature in many things and
an that in his gay science for through
his madman who was the herald of the
death of God aren't those
churches uh just a tombs and tombstones
of the Dead God and ask ask it the same
question in the pandemic in this
lockdown when the churches were closed I
wrote a book uh time of uh empty
churches and I as if the church if the
Christianity uh will not have a Revival
but not this revival in this Pentecostal
Evangelical way to go deeper to go
deeper uh so uh it may happen that the
churches will be just
the Tomb of the Dead God but the empty
tomb has in Christianity also another
meaning absolutely there are uh two
angels saying why do you seek uh the
living among the death so we shouldn't
uh seek the Living God Among the de in
the tombs we should go to the Galilee to
meet him again and uh I think the uh the
faith in the resurrection it is the
courage uh to seek uh the living uh to
to seek the Galilee of today to seek the
living the resurrection who is
absolutely transformed so the
resurrection is not uh to go back uh
some Revival of the dead corpse it is
the surprise absolutely surprise
something absolutely new
and uh also in the gospel the nearest
and deest of Jesus uh are not able to
recognize him Mar Magdalene Gardener and
so on and he's absolutely surprised and
uh the Apostle
Thomas the patron of us adapters he
recognized him by by by by by the Ws and
I think it is the sign we should uh
recognize the Living God living Christ
Living living culture Living spirit uh
the wounds uh because if we ignore the
wounds of our world we have no right to
say my Lord and my
God and Illusions but I think the wounds
of our words they are the place we can
meet the Living God in anonymity
and as a surprise and uh I think the uh
art is doing this and all practically
all uh the films we have
seen it was this topic the wounds uh the
wounds of our world they are the place
we can recognize something sacred in a
absolutely new way